Salut ! Vous avez compris en lisant le titre de la vidéo
qu'il m'était arrivé quelque chose d'un petit peu particulier.
Mais qui risque d'arriver à la plupart des mecs en plus.
Alors que tu sois un homme ou une fille je te conseille de regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au bout.
Je précise ça parce que j'ai regardé les statistiques de mon audience et mon audience est composée à
78 % d'hommes, de garçons et donc à 22 % de filles.
Parce que c'était important que ça fasse bien 100% quand même au final.
Et puis vous l'avez compris, il m'est donc arrivés très récemment quelque chose de très spécial, de très étrange.
Mais avant d'y venir, il faut que je vous précise quelque chose d'autre. Si on regarde les
480 vidéos que j'ai faites, la première vidéo se passe avec un mec, la deuxième avec une fille.
J'essaye de respecter une parité comme ça, fille/garçon.
A la base il n'y a même pas une volonté particulière, c'est en fait c'est juste logique c'est le quotidien quoi.
Et ce qui m'est arrivé c'est vraiment très particulier, c'est quelque chose donc que j'ai envie de dire mais je me dis
surtout que, si une fille tenait le discours que je vais tenir,
elle s'en prendrait plein à la gueule.
J'ai fait à peu près donc autant de featurings avec des filles qu'avec des garçons et à chaque fois, dans les commentaires, il y a quelque chose d'assez merveilleux.
Alors forcément il y a toujours des commentaires négatifs et des commentaires positifs, ça c'est normal.
Mais dans les commentaires négatifs,
je me suis aperçu de quelque chose d'assez fabuleux.
Quand j'ai un mec que quelqu'un n'aime pas sur ma chaîne,
les commentaires ont tendance à dénigrer le contenu qui produit sur sa propre chaîne.
Alors ça peut être violent, du style " ouais avec sa chaîne de merde"
"De toute manière, j'aime pas son contenu"
"c'est pourri ce qu'il fait"
Par contre à chaque fois que j'ai une fille sur la chaîne, dans les commentaires ce que je vais lire
c'est des critiques sur
bah sur euh... son physique
sur le fait qu'elle soit une fille, sur comment elles s'exprime ou elle s'exprime pas, si elle a l'air intelligente ou pas, sur les vêtements
qu'elle porte, sur le fait qu'on ait couché ensemble ou pas, sur le fait qu'elle ait couché avec d'autres youtubers ou pas, etc etc.
C'est fabuleux ça, d'un côté on juge le
contenu d'une personne et de l'autre côté on
juge en fait, le fait que ce soit une fille.
Alors j'ai décidé qu'aujourd'hui c'est moi qui avais mes règles.
Voilà comme ça c'est pour ça que je m'énerve. Mais je vous rassure c'est de l'énervement
maîtrisé. D'ailleurs que vous soyez une fille ou un garçon et que vous vous sentiez du bon côté
de la force ou du mauvais côté, dans ce que je raconte.
Vraiment regardez la vidéo en entier elle ne va pas être très longue.
Bon je suis pas féministe, d'ailleurs je sais même pas si un homme peut être féministe ou pas ou tes féministe ou pas.
J'ai fait aucune recherche là dessus donc je ne sais pas, par contre ce que je sais c'est que je suis pragmatique.
Ce que je viens de vous dire sur les commentaires c'est complètement pragmatique.
Quand le fait qu'on puisse s'apercevoir les commentaires qu'il y a des insultes qui sont unisexes.
Par exemple quand une youtubeuse viens sur ma chaîne et se fait insulter de Milf, je me dis "tiens
pourquoi jamais de mecs reçoivent une insulte un petit peu symétrique".
Ben parce que ça existe pas en fait. Une Milf il y a un vieuxbeau, c'est l'insulte la plus
approchante, un vieuxbeau. Et alors ça m'amène à comprendre quelque chose, des filles qui refuse maintenant de faire des
featuring sur les chaînes d'autres mecs parce qu'elles
en ont marre en fait de se faire insulter, parce qu'il faut quand même prendre conscience de quelque chose.
Quand on fait une vidéo avec
quelqu'un sur la chaîne de quelqu'un d'autre.
évidemment qu'on va lire les commentaires après.
On lit, on regarde un petit peu comment c'est accueilli, ce qu'on a fait qu'est ce que vous en pensez.
Évidemment !
Et quand je vois ce que je lis moi, rien que sur mes propres vidéos alors que je crois que j'ai plutôt de base une communauté bienveillante.
Je me dis que, ouais je comprends pourquoi elles refusent maintenant de faire des feats et je comprends aussi pourquoi il y a des filles qui
veulent plus se lancer sur YouTube ou qui arrêtent leurs chaînes ou qui a un bon projet de chaîne et qui ne le font pas.
Alors forcément les filles, elles se soutiennent entre elles, mais c'est pas normal.
On devrait avoir une communauté mixte un petit peu partout en fait et aussi
bienveillante.
Bon et puis si on fait une analyse rapide des commentaires, on va pas se mentir c'est toujours des commentaires
issus de la frustration sexuelle. Soit de gens qui arrivent pas à choper, soit de gens qui sont frustrés,
soit de gens à qui la fille rappelle quelqu'un avec qui ils ont eu des soucis
émotionnels, soit de gens lubriques, soit de gens qui ont des problèmes de libido.
Et en fait ça m'amène à dire quelque chose,
et tu vas voir la réflexion elle est intéressante.
C'est à dire que les mecs disent toujours quand une fille à un problème "Elle a ses règles,
elle devrait un petit peu se contenir, à se retenir,
et ce calmer un petit peu, ça va quoi !"
Mais nous les mecs on n'a pas un changement hormonal en permanence en fait, avec la libido exacerbée
qu'on retrouve dans les commentaires, qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs aussi dans la vie courante
malheureusement. Peut-être qu'elle géreront mieux leurs émotions
le jour où on va mieux gérer les notre de ce côté là.
Tu vois la mise en perspective des problèmes hormonaux.
Parce que vraiment, quand je lis les commentaires sur les chaînes des filles,
c'est ouf !
Bon et puis sur internet que ce soit sur YouTube sur des forums etc on le sait très bien.
L'anonymat aide est favorise ça malheureusement, et puis l'âge des personnes et je vais juste finir là-dessus.
Que vous soyez un mec qui pense
comme moi, quelqu'un qui fait partie de la fameuse majorité silencieuse
ou une fille.
Il faut absolument vous impliquer, mais pour ça c'est hyper simple.
N'entrez surtout pas en conflit avec ceux qui écrivent ces commentaires, c'est pas ce que
je vous demande vous allez perdre votre temps dans la plupart du temps.
Par contre vous pouvez:
signaler les commentaires offensants,
et encore plus important, ne plus laisser l'espace commentaires
aux mains et aux prises de ces gens là.
C'est à dire que sur une vidéo qui fait 100 000 vues,
imaginons qu'il y a 200 commentaires, sur les 200 commentaires
il y en a 100 hyper violents et négatifs comme ça.
Je parle bien de méchanceté gratuite !
Pas de critique constructive !
La fille qui lit les commentaires qui lui sont adressés
Elle va lire la moitié des messages.
Un sur deux là dessus.
Alors que nous on sait que c'est pas représentatif puisqu'il y a eu 100 000 vues
et c'est 100 commentaires sur 100 000 vues c'est que dalle !
Mais quand tu lis les commentaires
c'est la moitié de ce que tu lis.
Donc vous pouvez agir en étant vous même pas silencieux.
C'est à dire si vous avez aimé la personne, la vidéo, ce qu'elle fait.
Vous pouvez mettre un commentaire là dessus.
Vous savez c'est comme les votes extrêmes.
Les blaireaux il n'oublie jamais de donner leurs voix.
Eh bien là c'est pareil, les gros lourds n'oublie jamais de mettre un commentaire.
donc on peut tous se responsabiliser moi le premier
en mettant des commentaires sur les vidéos qu'on trouve cool,
quand on voit une fille qui se fait allumer dans les coms et qu'on n'est pas d'accord
et ben ça vaut le coup de mettre un commentaire positif pour contrecarrer ça.
Parce qu'il faut qu'on reprenne les espaces commentaires aussi un petit peu en main.
Voilà je pense que cette vidéo était un petit peu fouillis
mais je pense aussi que vous avez compris le message que je voulais donner
et ce n'était pas vraiment un coup de gueule c'était plus un constat.
Peut-être un petit réveil de deux trois personnes,
au moins se seraient déjà génial !
Et maintenant je pense que vous avez compris pourquoi j'ai mis ce titre.
Si une fille
avait eu le malheur de faire exactement la vidéo que je viens de faire,
dans les commentaires on lui aurait dit:
"Oh c'est bon, elle a ses règles!"
*musique*